during the democratic presidential
primaries
entrepreneurial candidate andrew yang
took an old american idea
and made it the core of his campaign one
of the central elements of my campaign
is the freedom dividend
where every american receives one
thousand dollars a month free and clear
paid for by a new tax on the companies
that are benefiting most
from new technologies since the pandemic
ravaged the global economy
and put millions of americans out of
work universal basic income
or a ubi is gaining traction as a viable
option to fight poverty although yang
made ubi a mainstream term during the
primaries
the idea itself has actually been around
since thomas fan advocated for it
in 1797. dr martin luther king jr was
also a supporter
michael tubbs is the 29 year old mayor
of stockton california
his city launched a ubi program where
125 residents received 500
a month from february 2019 to june 2020
it was renewed and will continue until
january 2021.
now mirrors in a number of cities
including atlanta
newark and los angeles are looking to
launch their own ubi pilot programs
this is all part of a coalition cubs
founded known as mayors for a guaranteed
income
it's saying that we trust our residents
with regular cash payments to solve a
lot of these issues we pull our hair out
trying to solve
it that doesn't absolve us of our jobs
but it does
allow us to highlight that there are
some gaps to how much we can be
that as a mayor none of us are smart
enough to think about the ways that
collectively the over 7 million people
in our cities
can use money or will need to use money
every month
and that doesn't mean get rid of things
like rental assistance
necessary food stamps necessary
but it's saying those things are
necessary but not sufficient tubs says
each city and the coalition will launch
its own pilot program
either by creating a working group to
find room in city budgets or by forming
public and private partnerships
just recently twitter and square ceo
jack dorothy donated 3 million dollars
to the program
newark mayor ross j baraka expects most
recipients will be using the extra money
for basic needs such as housing
food and utilities it would be
successful
if we saw that the money we gave
stabilized people's families that
allowed them to pay their rent
without any issue 78 of the people in
this city are renters
so it allowed them to pay their rent it
allowed them to
the quality of life to change uh because
of this and
and if they if we poll uh when we do the
research and then it tells us that
they feel uh more secure because of the
i think that that's a home run
[Music]
you